You're right. Its really hard to keep track of where you are.
>> Exactly. And the replication machinery inside
your cell has an equally difficult time.
It literally slips on these repeat regions,
which can cause deletions or additions of sequence.
>> You know, I think, you're right, I've heard about this
before. In psychology, there's a disorder where there's repeats in the CAG?
>> Yeah, so that's called Huntington's Disease.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> Huntington's Disease is a neurodegenerative disorder
affecting the brain, and eventually causing death. Due
to an abnormal number of repeat regions in
a gene within your genome specifically the CAG
repeats. Now a normal person unaffected by Hungtington's,
would have around 25 or possibly fewer CAG
repeats. But as repeat errors occur, if you
get up to 40 or more CAG repeats,
then you're going to be someone who's affected by Huntington's.
>> So having repeats causes
slippage in the first place, then having more repeats, will it just
cause more slippage and more likely to pass it down to your children?
>> Unfortunately, that's true. And that's
exactly what happened to an individual
named Katherine Moser whose story was written about in the New York Times.
At age 23 Miss Moser found out well before the onset of Huntington's
that she had 45 CAG repeats. More than her grandfather had who
actually died of Huntington's.
>> It's just a really sad story.
>> It's really unfortunate also because there's currently no cure
for Huntington's. All we can do is treat the symptoms.
>> I want to ask, would you want to know how many
CAG repeats you had and if you're going to develop Huntington's.